.
WEATCH THE FIRSTO START WITH ONT
RAMASWAMST DEBAT
HITH
G BANNED ON GOVERNMENT
ISSUED DEVICES, BECAUSE OF ITS
TIES TO CHINA.
>> THIS IS INFURIATING, BECAUSTS
HAVE.
HAVE,RYI
DUMBER FROM WHAT YOU SAY.
THAT MEANS THEY CAN T YOURAR
CONTACTS, YOUR FINANCIAL
CAN YOHEY
N
DOING AND WHAT WE --
A THAT IS KIDS T
DANGERFOS.
WE CAN'T T YRUST YOU.THE CHINES
>> YOU HAVE
WHILE MOST MOMMY.
>> I TNK WWOED AS A REPUBLICAN Y
IF WE ARE NOT SITTINHEIND
>> SO AVDEBATE ABOUTOL
T HERE, DCTAND VID INU MAKEF
>> IT WAS FEIS
, THE
TRUMP IROUGHL300ION
W HAMPE,THIS CHANGE ANYTHINGYOU,
A T PRIMARY SECON
E.I  YCAYBE HAD A MOMENT.
BUT THEN TO FUNDAMENTA
CHANGE, ANYTHING IMY ANSWER IS .
THE REPUBLICANS WHO DO THIS FOR
A LIVINGTHERE'AN DAYSE THIRD, DN
CANDESAN
WIRIOD.
>> NIKKI H DEFTRNG THE SUCCESS
SHE E FIRST TIME IN
OVIVEK MAR
NTIS.
>> ALSO, SHE GOTH
MA END, IN A WAYHATCUY HELPFUTOH
NODOE DID THIS DEBATET RA
BEERN DESANTIS
BURN HERETE AGGRESSIVRE S
WITH FOF THIS IT SEEMS TO MEDONR
MORE OF A MODEL FOR
VOTERS.
SO, BY THEWAY FOR ALL OF T
NDTS AT TRUMP.
ENT RIGHT FOR THE
ARY, NOT EJACULATORY.
SO HE BASICALLY GOT
DAMAGE,
THSE WAS AD FO TRUMP IN EN>> ITI
HIR FOURTH
AMONG A BUNCOFIT WN'T --
E, SOME PEOPLE HAD
MEENY HAD A
OOD STRONG MOMENTS THAT
MADE HER SND OUT.
T E FIGHTING FOR THE
BOTTOM OF THE RACE RIGHT NOW.
THATTHE FRONT
DIFFERENT VIEW
OF THE DESTIS OF IT L, I
THOUGHHE WASKAY.
HE FADED INTTHE BA,
FIRST HALF OF
ID NOT SPEAK F A THE
FIRST 15 MINUTES.
THE CENTER OEDEBATE SECKED MY C-
ITOOK HIA WHILE TO
INS FOOTIN
HE IS REALLY THE PERWHO
OUGHT TO HAVE THST MOMENTUMT W.H
ISLLUP IN
RACE.
NE OTHER QUICKOINT ON
.
AYS LET YOU KNOW
WHO HE IS MAD AT, TH UP
L STEMING THE DEBATE WAS
BORING AND HORT ONE STATENATTAC.
BULSABOUAT>> THAT IS WHAT I WAS,
SAIF THERE IS A WINNER ON THE
STAGE TONIGHT, I THINK IT
NIKKI HALEY.
VI CHRISTENINGON WE KEEP
ASND.THIS E TIME, TH
AVDROP OUT AND
E IF THEY WAODEFEAT TRUMP.
WHAT I SNCH OF PEOPLAR ATTACK EH
OTHEER EVERY SINGLE POLICY
FORCE ONSTAGE IS HOWERYONE SEEM.
NOTHTH WAS GOING TO
HROUGH FTHIS DEBATE
M NOT SURE I WOULD EXPECT TOLITI
SEE A MAJOR BOOMNY
ALLUDED T
EVERYONE ISTKETS
SHAROM EACH OTHEE ARE WAY FROM .
TOMORROW GR DESANTIS WHO
HARO CINK
GOVERNOR CHRISTIE LAST
ESOFBATE.
SHOTS.HE PROBLEM IN EEMEDY
THE'T OF
N THE NEXT 40 YSE ND. THAT CHRIE
--
E MIDDLE, HE IS THE
SURVIVOR AT THE END OF THE
GAME.
>>TRUMP HE ISLAND.
THE, ISLAND WITHUATION --
NEIEE
, WE AREIT
WATCHING THIS.
NG
>> THE FIGHTING.
BETTER VITRII THOUGHT THE LAST T
AT THEDENTER OF
N.LE LIKELT AL, HA ZEITGEIST JUT
FOR MONTHS WITHOUT WHO COULD AEE
TIME, BIDEN
IGH-SP APART
OOK AT THESE NATIOL
EPBEEN IN THE, SKY WE CAN'T LOSE
GET VINDICATION.
INT BATE ORSOMEONE MEL
HAVIT IS B AREASONS NIKKI LE
CLEARS THE MARGIN OF ERRNS.IKE
SO OUEELBEST C
SHE DID M AT
ALL TONIGHT.
IN THE POL, YHE WAS IN
DIDN'T THINK THAT WAS A
COMPELLING ARGUMT REASON SCOTTD,
I WOULD LIKE TO ASK YOU
GUYS,  I ME THEY
WERE MOMENTS THERE LIKE WHEN HE
WENT COUNTER TO A NU OPEOPLE OU.
WA SIDE OF THIS
ISSUE, PERSOLLTHERE A LOT OF
VOTE IPUIMARIES, IF YOU FO POLLE
KRAINE.
HEOOA RYG POSI
HAT.
OSE KIS E
PPL
ARE OUT IN, IOWANEW STATES YOU
HAMPSHIRE.
MAY REGISTER WITOSVO HE UNEQUIVN
EBATE
LY NOTICING YOU
COKIHE
U MENTIONESTORY ABOUT HIS,
WIFE HE TRD GRAVE TE, AN--
WHEN HE WAS TALKING ABOUSO F PUE
UNIONS A STRIKING, HE
EXPRESSED SYMPAT FOR WORKERS.
ONE OF H SSTIF QUESTION THATPUTO
THESE S
N YEARS,GO IT
ANERROUNESE
ING ON THIS >>AR
ING A MUCHE
NCE, ITO DO WI